okay so I've been meaning to talk about
this case for a few days and I haven't
really had a chance to get into it yet
so let's do that now as The Daily wire
reported this week a former star
football player for Baylor University
and a certainly a surefire early round
pick probably a first-round NFL draft
pick was acquitted in a high-profile
rape case a few days ago now so the the
accuser claimed that the player whose
name is Shawn Oakman we don't know the
accusers name the media reports don't
include it because she's an alleged rape
victim she says she says that Oakman
raped her in his apartment near campus
near Baylor University but it took the
jury only about two hours for them to
come to the conclusion that he's not
guilty and that's that's not a long
deliberation especially for a case like
this but when you look at the specifics
of the case it's kind of easy to see why
it didn't take them very long and it
makes you wonder why this ever went to
trial in the first place because there
is such a lack of evidence to support
the accusers claims basically the only
evidence here that the the prosecution
had three avenues of evidence if we
could even call this evidence they had
the word of the accuser obviously they
had the testimony of a few of her
friends who say that now they didn't
witness the assault but they they talk
to her after the fact and they found her
disheveled and distraught and crying
they say and she told them what she
claims happened and then and then they
had injuries especially genital injuries
to the woman which medical experts for
the defense testified could have easily
been sustained in a consensual encounter
with a this is a you know the man is 300
pounds six foot seven so so that was
that's what they had that's pretty much
it
the defense though had quite a bit more
evidence number one the woman texted
Oatman with with whom she'd previously
had a sexual relationship she texted him
to come meet her at the bar on the night
when the assault allegedly occurred then
she willingly went back to oak man's
apartment even texting a friend on the
way to indicate that she was okay
oke man's roommate who was who was in
the apartment when the alleged assault
took place he testified that there he
didn't hear any screams he didn't hear
any indication of a struggle coming from
the defendants bedroom the woman said
that she was too drunk to consent but
then multiple witnesses came forward to
say that they interacted with her that
night she was seemed perfectly lucid
there was also evidence that the accuser
what I want to get too graphic there was
there was based on DNA evidence the
accuser alleged that certain sexual acts
took place against her will that she was
she tried to leave she was physically
prevented and then she was pinned down
and certain things well they were able
to nearly do DNA tests they could kind
of reconstruct what sorts of sexual acts
took place that night and that did not
match with what the accuser said also a
forensic digital analyst took the stand
and said that somebody deleted text
messages from the woman's phone the text
messages where she asked Oakman to come
to the bar someone deleted those text
messages which is highly suspicious
so Oakman had physical evidence
circumstantial evidence physical
evidence will be you know the DNA
evidence circumstantial evidence would
be the fact that she asked him to come
out then she went back to his apartment
they had a previous sexual relationship
so we can we can assume that she she
knew what was going on when she went
back to the apartment and she she
herself had certain intentions in mind
and then he also had eye witnesses I
mean he had someone that was in the
apartment when this was supposedly
happening who said that there was no
indication of anything like what she's
talking about
so it's no wonder that the jury jury
came to the conclusion that it did
that's the only conclusion it possibly
could come to there's just no reason to
convict the guy unless you're just going
to believe the woman's story even
instead of all of this other it wasn't
not just a he said she said it was a she
said he said plus he has all this
evidence so there's no way that the she
said can outweigh all of that or at
least it should but you know the thing
is the story doesn't end there for
Oakman because he's gonna have to wear
the accused rapists label around his
neck for the rest of his life you don't
just you don't just go through something
like that and then go and live your life
like it never happened
for the rest of his life he's gonna be
the guy who was accused and went to
trial for rape and he's never gonna be
able to escape that escape that and even
if he's still able to salvage some kind
of a football career which which seems
likely because given his talent and the
fact that he could now be I'm sure some
team will take a chance on him and and
financially it's gonna be low risk for
them because they're not gonna have to
pay him very much which just shows that
he also lost quite a bit of money if he
had gone in the first round well there's
me a lot of money and a lot of
professional prestige and and job
security that comes with that that now
he's not ever gonna be able to recoup
that's just gone right now of course
it's still possible it's still possible
that Oakman did what he was accused of
doing
we don't know court cases are not
designed to prove anyone innocent but
just to decide whether the prosecution
has succeeded in proving them guilty so
all the jury is saying is the jury isn't
saying this guy's innocent the jury is
saying you prosecution did not do your
job you did not could succeed in proving
him guilty so who knows and that's sort
of the point here that if he is innocent
which perfectly possible plausible maybe
even likely that he is innocent well if
he is
Michels even more the injustice that the
rest of us have to say yo it's possible
that he did it I mean I don't know it's
he certainly did not it was certainly
the right decision to not find him
guilty but who knows what actually
happened and there are a few you know
there are a few factors that do weigh in
the in the accusers favor I think
primarily the fact that she did not wait
30 years you know like Chris Christine
Ford to make this accusation she made it
very soon after the fact and she told
her friends you know
shortly after happened that they found
her and she was crying and she was
clearly distressed about something and
she told them what happened that is a
you know that fact alone is probably why
the deliberations lasted two hours
rather than two minutes because you do
have to weigh that you have to say well
I mean did she decide right then and
there that she was gonna make up this
lie which was that all an act or her
friend's lying well I think no not
necessarily that there is a way to
explain all of that without without
necessarily painting this woman as just
an abject liar and I'll talk about that
in a minute it's just we have to
emphasize that given the physical
evidence the eye witnesses the fact that
she sought out Oakman and chose to go
back to his apartment indicating it
would seem at least at first that she
had the intention of having sexual
relationships with him it just it's it's
it's seems just as likely if not more
likely that the encounter was entirely
consensual because a woman doesn't
generally go back to old man's apartment
after having a few drinks late at night
if she does not have that intention now
a friend of hers did testify that she
only went back to his apartment because
she wanted to see his new puppy but that
actually you know a claim like that
really just casts even more suspicion on
the accuser because there's just no way
I mean there's it seems it's it's highly
unlikely that a woman you know a
college-age woman in modern society
would think that after you have some
drinks with a guy that you've already
been sexually active with and you go
back to his apartment after a bar at
night it just seems highly unlikely that
that you know that either person would
did not have in mind that we're probably
going to have sex tonight
it just seems highly unlikely so what
lesson can we learn from this well I
think the same thing we've learned
countless times already which is we
can't believe all women as the hashtag
urges us to do we have to draw our
conclusions based on evidence not based
on gender
now the proponents of the believe all
women method they would have us give the
benefit of the doubt to the accuser and
if the fact what they basically say is
if the facts could vindicate her claims
if there is some way to theoretically
make it all gel with her version of
events then that's what we should do
believe all women wants us at a minimum
to interpret the fact in whatever light
is most favorable to the woman but that
is precisely the wrong approach
we should interpret the facts in the
most reasonable plausible way and if the
facts could go one way or another and
there's no way to draw a any conclusion
with any degree of rational certainty
then we have to be satisfied with
drawing no conclusion and saying you
know we don't know what happened but we
can't we can't assume that the guy's a
rapist so we just we don't know and we
it's we got to just leave it there
that's the problem is that this believe
all women that slogan is really designed
for cases like Oakman because after all
you don't need to get in to believe all
women if the accused if the accused
rapist is clearly guilty if there's a
lot of evidence if he's clearly guilty
then we don't need to get in to believe
all women it's just clearly there's no
need for slogans the slogan only comes
into play
it would seem in precisely a situation
like this where yeah maybe the guy's
guilty there's a very good
he's not and that's where the me2
proponents swoop in and they insist that
in the absence of certainty we assume
guilt which is a horrible and completely
unethical and dangerous way of going
about things one other point here the
insistence by feminists in expanding on
expanding the definition of rape
expanding it to the point of absurdity I
think that makes it more difficult to
get to the truth in any situation
especially a situation like this the way
that we talk about consent and the way
that we've made rape into this very
broad category it only makes everything
convoluted and more confused so let's
imagine a hypothetical here nobody but
Oakman and his accuser know what really
happened that night no one else is ever
going to know but let's imagine a
perfectly plausible hypothetical let's
imagine something that falls sort of
in-between Oakman being a rapist on one
hand and his accuser being a liar on the
other hand now feminists don't allow for
gray areas in these situations but I
think that's where the truth often often
falls with this sort of thing so imagine
that Oakman and the woman go back to his
apartment
both intending on sexual relations then
let's say the woman at some point
realizes that she isn't into it doesn't
really want to do it let's say that
Oakman then tries to convince her
pressures are a little bit not
physically but just not with threats or
anything like that but just tries to
convince her to do what he wants to do
and then let's say that she agrees of
her own free will
she's not prevented from leaving she
could leave but she she agrees after
some convincing and she goes through
with the act even though she didn't she
didn't really want to she wasn't that
into it now the left tells us that that
would be rape if there is no continuous
and enthusiastic and they put that in
it has to be enthusiastic continuous
enthusiastic affirmative consent all the
way through in the absence of that it's
rape they say but that's absurd of
course it's not it's not rape that
wouldn't be rape it wouldn't be good
either but the left has created a
dynamic this is this is the dynamic that
crazy they say all sex falls into two
cavities there's only two categories of
sex there's there's good wonderful sex
and then there's rape nothing in between
if it's not good and wonderful it's rape
that's what they say those are the only
categories but in reality there's a lot
of room in between it is possible to
have bad immoral sexual relations the
kind that may leave a person feeling
used
dirty guilty whatever but which was
entirely consensual and thus not rape
those kinds of sexual relations happen
all the time especially on college
campuses and I think that's why we hear
about one in four women are sexually
assaulted well some of those women
counted in that statistic really were
sexually assaulted but I think a lot of
them what actually happened is they
consensually had sex that they didn't
really want to have but they did it
anyway
by expanding the definition of rape to
include cases where there was actually
consent by both parties the left has
diminished the severity of rape and
created a whole mess of false rape
claims that the person making the false
rape claim might not even know is false
so back to my hypothetical it's
perfectly possible even plausible that
the woman went through with the act
completely consensually but she wasn't
that into it and she later realizes
based on what we're told these days she
later realizes that oh I was raped and
she comes to believe that she really was
raped and then she maybe embellishes the
story a little bit when she talks to the
cops and she talks and she tells people
about it she embellishes a little bit
just because she knows that if she tells
the story exactly as it happened it
won't sound like rape and maybe that's
why she goes back and she deletes the
text message and she does all this stuff
she really believes that something did
that she was assaulted but she knows
that if
the exact sequence of events wouldn't
support that claim so she changes a
little a little bit I look I don't know
if that's actually what happened but my
point is that in our culture we we we
have now an environment that would
create and encourage those kinds of
situations situations where no rape
occurs but the person making the false
rape claim may not realize it's false
because they've been given a false
definition of rape they have been told
that you may be raped even if you
consent to the act which is totally
absurd the the definition of rape is to
have sex with someone or they've said
any kind of sexual contact with a person
against their will that's what rape is
anything that is not that is not rape
but it could still be bad it could still
be immoral it could still be unadvisable
it could still be a lot of bad things so
you know good moral wonderful affirming
loving sex is is one category and I
would say that that that's a category
that belongs entirely in the bonds of
marriage and then so you have that and
then you've got rape all the way over
here and but then you've got a lot I
mean the left are the ones who usually
are all about spectrums and gray areas
well here is a place where you've got
something like that where you've got a
lot of stuff in-between here where it's
not it's not rape it's not good and
wonderful either and if you fall into
that middle ground you you you're gonna
you may leave the act but whether you're
a woman or a man feeling used feeling
because you were used right there's
there's a lot that's that's the problem
with the these one-night stands and the
hookup culture and everything is that
people men and women they use each other
physically they're not raping each other
because they both agree to it but they
use each other and then and then later
on they they are left feeling used and
they may now interpret they may say oh I
was used
so I was raped not necessarily
if you consented to it it's not rape but
it was still not good still something we
should discourage all right uh let's
move on an article on The Daily wire
right now Girl Scouts gives highest
award to to a girl who organized a
pro-abortion campaign so if you didn't
if you didn't already realize this about
the Girl Scouts here's a little bit from
this article though the organization's
ties to abortion conglomerate Planned
Parenthood have been known for years the
Girl Scouts of America have yet to be so
forthright about their closeted support
for abortion until now according to life
news the group My Girl Scout Council
calm has been monitoring the
organization for years over its
pro-abortion stance and it discovered
last Friday that the Girl Scouts of
southern Arizona
honored a girl for her volunteer work on
reproductive health justice Meghna
Gopalan recently profiled in a Tucson
publication received the gold award the
Girl Scouts highest honor for her work
reports LifeNews her project involved
working with the pro-abortion women's
March and its affiliate in Tucson she
said her goal was to educate people and
D stigmatize access to women's health
care euphemisms for abortion she said
I'm planning on hosting an event to
educate people about about and D
stigmatized access to women's health
care I've been working with the El Rio
reproductive health access project and
they've offered ideas and reproductive
health justice which would broaden the
scope of the project a little bit blah
blah blah
so Girl Scouts working now with
reproductive health justice and this of
course is just another example of the
ideological piracy that left us engage
in where they invade institutions that
commandeer them and they turn them into
agents of their own agenda and they've
done that to the Boy Scouts and and the
Girl Scouts as well where the Girl Scout
here's what's happened the Boy Scouts
have become the Girl Scouts and the Girl
Scouts have become a wing of Planned
Parenthood that that's what's happened
thanks to the left all right I want to
talk about one other thing before we get
the emails something that has nothing to
do with politics or anything like that I
found this article linked on Drudge this
morning on a website called the ladders
dot-com and it has an interesting little
tidbit that I thought I'd mention an
author named Tom Corley who wrote a book
called rich habits the daily success
habits of rich individuals and he
doesn't in this book he does a survey of
a bunch of different young millionaires
and there was this fact that I thought
was relevant the fact is according to
the survey that he did the majority of
the young and successful people that he
spoke to or C's students in school most
of them were not very successful in
school academically they were C's
students which puts you which means
you're not far above failing right at
that point that's an interesting fact
doesn't surprise me and you hear this a
lot about really successful people where
they didn't do well in school
and a lot of them didn't even go to
college not academic success stories in
other words but then they go on and they
become success stories out in the world
I mean we all we all know the story
about Albert Einstein it was not a very
good student I think those stories are
probably exaggerated a little bit but
but still it's it's all part of this now
it's worth asking well why is that how
could it be that you could have people
who are brilliant and very talented and
hardworking and ambitious and ambitious
and all that which is what you would
need to be to succeed in the world but
how could you have someone like that who
who who who can't handle you know grade
school I think it's because the
education system emphasizes demands
certain skills certain qualities that
have nothing to do with intelligence
nothing to do with ingenuity nothing to
do
creativity or any of the things that the
education system should be fostering
here are these are really the two
qualities that you need to have in order
to do well in school these are the only
two you have to be good at memorizing
and regurgitating information and you
have to be good at sitting still for
long stretches while performing rote
busy work those are the two skills you
need to have if you have those qualities
you will be an A+ student pretty much
guaranteed you could have an IQ of 85
you could be a in fact I went to school
with plenty of kids who I don't know
what their IQ was but they were clearly
not very smart some of them frankly
appeared to be huge dummies but just in
talking to them right you just have a
conversation you realize well you are
kind of stupid
you don't say it to their face maybe
sometimes you do you shouldn't but they
would get eight they get straight A's
and then and then of course for for a
lot of kids they think well I'm
definitely smarter than that person why
am I getting C's over here because well
just because if you have the if you can
sit still and not think about anything
else
and just think about your busy work and
you can memorize and then regurgitate
what you're told you'll do great and
those are good abilities to have by the
way I'm not knocking them but they
aren't abilities that will necessarily
translate to success and fulfillment
outside of school so there's a huge
disparity where success in education
depends entirely on qualities that of
themselves won't do much for you outside
of education and that's a big problem
see that's something we really need to
focus on now if you can sit still
memorize and you happen to be a
brilliant logical thinker or very gifted
in math or you happen to be very
scientifically minded or you're also
artistic well then that combination
absolutely will lead to success outside
of school that will that will give you
success in school and in life so best of
both worlds when you find people who got
more straight-a students all
through and then they go out there and
they become extremely successful in
whatever they're doing well well that's
someone
yeah that's best of both worlds that's
someone who could sit still memorize
regurgitate and also happen to be
brilliant and was a hard worker
ambitious creative if you got all that
going for you well then you're gonna
basically coast through life and good
for you in that case
but what if see there are a lot of
people what if you what if you have
trouble sitting still
you aren't great at memorization but
you're also extremely creative or what
if you aren't great at sitting still and
memorizing but you're very gifted with
building things or fixing things or what
if you can't sill sit still can't
memorize and regurgitate but you're a
great writer and yes there are a lot of
writers who have trouble sitting still
I'm one of them although I wouldn't call
myself a great writer or let's say you
have a great interest in in history and
you have a keen eye for history or what
if you're a gifted artist so you're a
compelling public speaker or you're a
budding inventor or you have a great
business sense or you're a natural
salesman and so on what have you have
those qualities but you can't really sit
still and you can't regurgitate and
memorize well all of those kinds of
people that those are very gifted they
could all be extremely successful in
life I mean any any of those people
could they gif if they wanted to they
could turn that into you know they can
become built become billionaires with
those qualities so there's nothing wrong
with any of them but all of them will
struggle mightily in school and many of
them will probably end up on
psychotropic drugs because it will be
decided that they have ADHD and so on
and that's the whole problem with our
system is that it's only built for one
kind of person and no one else and it
and it's often caters to qualities that
in
cases do not translate you know as I
said if you have the ability to sit
still
memorize regurgitate and you also happen
to have other great qualities well then
yeah that'll translate but that ability
just on its own well I mean that'll be
good to put you in a cubicle you know
you could take that and go sit in a
cubicle or work at the DMV or something
and nothing wrong with doing either
those things I'm just saying that's
those qualities isolated that's kind of
where that leads and it's so there's
just it's an entire paradigm shift that
needs to happen with our education
system we just our education system is
so deeply flawed down to its very roots
it is just it's not doing what it's
supposed to do and in the meantime and
that wouldn't be so bad in and of itself
but the problem is then you've got a lot
of really gifted kids very intelligent
they've got bright future ahead of them
but they go through 12 or 13 years of
school and they're just beaten down by
it because that's the other thing
there's an emotional and psychological
toll in in being forced every day
especially as a kid to be in an
environment that isn't suited for you
and where you're destined to fail
constantly believe me I went through
this myself where you know you know you
you go through your whole formative all
your formative years you're in this
environment where it is it is not made
for you and so every day you're just
failing and you're doing bad and you're
you know it's just constantly every day
and after a while it creates a complex
where kids begin to believe that arms
there somewhere all will be I'm stupid
and that can have fun you know hopefully
a kid will be able to cope with that and
eventually get out of school and realize
that oh no there's nothing wrong there's
something wrong with the system not
something wrong with me there are a lot
of things I can do well then they'll go
and do those things but I think there
are a lot of kids who are not able to
cope and they end up on drugs
whether legal or illegal you know they
end up going off on a wrong path that
commits suicide
you know worst case scenario there's
this part of where I think the suicide
epidemic among our kids happens it's not
normal to have all these kids committing
suicide it's not a normal thing and I
think part of that is also this these
these kids are worn down by the system
and they are made to feel totally
worthless and just crazy almost like
there's something completely wrong with
them when they're when there isn't
anything wrong with them
all right let me get to some emails
before you wrap up here Matt Walsh Oh at
gmail.com
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com let's start
with this from Dustin can I just say
that of all the idiots
in all the idiot villages and all the
idiot worlds you stand alone my friend
who do you think you are what gives you
the right I hate so much about the way
you choose to be Dustin I deeply
appreciate that feedback and I will take
it into consideration from Nick he says
hey Matt I just wanted to share an
interesting observation that occurred to
me recently about the left's abortion
arguments they seemed to break down into
two camps one set of arguments seek to
define life itself viability
consciousness ability to feel pain etc
the other seeks to justify abortion
bodily autonomy overpopulation
congenital defects cetera but it seems
like if you're going to argue for the
right to abortion that it's justified
then that presupposes that the fetus is
a life if you believe the fetus is just
a clump of cells then why would you need
to make a case for the right to get rid
of it it's like arguing for the right to
scrape gum off the bottom of your shoe
love the show thanks for all you do I
think that you make a very insightful
point Nick and I think you're exactly
right
and in fact so you do have those two
veins of argument where the argument
over life and then the argument over
just abortion and bodily autonomy in
everything now what the pro-abortion
advocates have done is they are
increasingly abandoning that first
category which that used to be what
there used to be this the centerpiece of
the abortion debate
was about definition of life and all of
that personhood but I think abortion
advocates are getting away from that for
two reasons number one that argument
focuses for them uncomfortably so it
focuses on the life on the child and
they don't want to they don't want to
bring attention to that and also they're
losing that argument they know that
they've arted they've lost it they've
lost that argument you know fifty years
ago I was different but but now we just
we know too much about what is really
going on inside the womb you can look at
the at the sonograms we know too much
about fetal development and so it's just
it's a difficult argument for them to
make now so now they're going over there
here and they're saying okay well forget
about that doesn't matter what the fetus
is all that matters is I have a right to
my autonomy and hey you know basically
their argument now is I should be able
to get an abortion because I want to get
an abortion and I should be able to do
what I want to do that's their argument
it's a bad argument it's a stupid
argument it's flawed in about a million
different ways but at least it's not as
easily that's more of a philosophical
argument it's not a scientific one so
there's scientific argument of oh this
isn't a human that isn't a person well
we can just disprove that easily just
show them a sonogram boom you're done or
we get into genetics and DNA you know
their own unique DNA so you know it's
over but an argument of I can I should
be able to do what I want well that's
the stats the argument of a
three-year-old but it's it is more of a
philosophical there's not one thing you
can present to them to prove that
they're wrong about that so I think
you're right
let's see is from Scott Matt I love your
show I'm a big fan of your opinions for
the most part for the most part good
qualify the first time I'm a fan of my
opinions for the most part as well the
first time I heard you was the episode
talking about how loving animals like
humans is immoral and I thought the
exact same thing most of my adult life
from then on I've made it a point to
catch her podcast during the day
I'm watching the HBO documentary about
Michael Jackson I started doing some
thinking about pedophilia we all know
the less goal is to take every immoral
act according to God and normalize it
Canada has a story recently about how a
court ruled a fourteen-year-old can
consent to gender reassignment
procedures by that logic a child is
equal to an adult and can make very
permanent decisions about their life do
you think this is a step towards
attempting to normalize pedophilia in
our society if a child can decide what
gender they are why can't they decide
who they love how can anyone else say
what they feel is not love if a parent
can't stop a child from taking steps
towards trying to change their gender
then how can they have the authority to
tell their child they can't have a
relationship with an adult maybe I'm
crazy but I definitely don't think this
is something far off and I won't be
shocked to see pedophilia rallies and
pride parades eventually people call me
crazy like you said just give it a new
name and suddenly you have a community
Scott I think that you are exactly right
I made that same point myself if we are
saying that an eight-year-old child has
the ability and the wherewithal and the
maturity and the autonomy to decide
their own gender then I mean it seems
like we've set the stage to say that
okay well maybe they actually have the
ability and maturity to make other
decisions as well so yes I think that
there is a link between those two issues
and I think that that is where we're
headed this is from Marissa says hi Matt
loved the show just wanted to comment on
the Captain Marvel issue I don't plan on
watching the movie in fact call me
sexist I'm a woman by the way but I
don't really think the whole female act
I don't really like the whole female
action hero thing personally I do prefer
men in those roles
I think female action heroes can often
come across pretty cheesy I guess I lose
my woman card for that well I lose my
woman card tumors because I agree with
you
well I mean I know what you mean oh and
put it that way I think well here's the
problem with female action heroes and I
know I'm gonna get myself into trouble
with this but I think a lot of people
will agree with both of us but they just
they feel like they can't say it like
most of us yeah I mean
well if you had a choice I mean if you
were given a choice but between watching
a movie with a male action hero a female
action hero and you didn't know anything
else about the movies you probably
choose the male action hero 1 right
because usually those characters tend to
be more compelling and there's a higher
likelihood that the female action hero
will be kind of corny and you'll just
kind of roll your eyes and all right
especially and and I've heard people say
well the you know it's in fact I think
was bill burr comedian who he had a line
of paraphrasing but he said that his his
suspension of disbelief can't handle you
know a cute blonde chick beating up a
bunch of Navy SEALs it's just like it's
a little bit too much actions movies
already are fanciful but when you add
that into it it's like yeah come on that
that I don't think is exactly the
problem because especially if you're
talking about a superhero well if the
woman has superpowers then she can do
whatever she wants but I think here's
the issue
the iconic super the iconic action
heroes the ones that we remember the
really compelling ones they always have
a kind of gritty and intimidating vibe
to them like there's always people
they're always people that you wouldn't
want to tick off right think of John
wick or John McCain McClane diehard Liam
Neeson and taken or in anything he's
done Daniel Craig Jason Statham go back
to Arnold Schwarzenegger Stallone any of
those guys they've got that kind of
gritty tough intimidating you know you
wouldn't want to take them off you
certainly would want to kidnap one of
their family members and hold them for
ransom
especially to Liam Neeson most of all so
but someone like brie Larson you know no
offense there but she just doesn't have
that intimidation factor like nobody if
you heard that brie Larson was coming
after you you're just not gonna be that
worried about it the same way that you'd
be worried if the rock was coming after
you right now so there's that
intimidation factor that I think that
grittiness and intimidation factor and
you need that most of the time in an
action hero it's harder for females to
have that but there are exceptions
uma Thurman in Kill Bill definitely had
that you would want to tick her off
Sigourney Weaver had it there are other
examples and there are exceptions on the
other side too I mean Tom Cruise is
maybe the greatest action star of all
time he's certainly not gritty or
intimidating but he makes up for that
with just sheer exuberance and
physicality doing his own crazy stunts
and everything and nearly killing
himself on every film shoot he's ever
been on so you know there are exceptions
but it's just there's a certain vibe
usually that an action hero needs to
bring to the table which a woman isn't
able to do quite as naturally which is
no knock on women there are Vai there's
a there there there are vibes that women
bring to the table that wit that men
wouldn't be able to quite as naturally
and in fact you take a movie like Kill
Bill or take aliens Sigourney Weaver I
think if you'd put a man in that role
you would have lost something so in that
case she had the kind of greatness
intimidation thing going on and but
there was also some but her femininity
brought to the role as well really
elevated it and helped make it an iconic
role and movie but you know it's like I
said it's just it's I think it's harder
for a female actor to bring that
especially someone like brie Larson but
not an insult all I'm saying is brie
Larson is not Liam Neeson which she
should be flattered that I would say
that because she shouldn't want to be
Liam Neeson all right um let's see this
is from this is from M just the letter M
is all I'm giving Matt you keep
contradicting yourself
one minute you're talking about due
process and believing evidence the next
year
condemning Michael Jackson as a
pedophilic monster I always respected
your opinion but your tirades against MJ
have exposed so much hypocrisy I've lost
a lot of respect for you okay and that's
fine
of course you completely missed the
point though my whole point all week has
been that there's overwhelming evidence
a whole truckload of evidence against
Jackson that's why I condemn them as a
pedophilic monster because you
was look bit okay I bet this is the last
thing I'm gonna say about this alright
I'm not gonna I'm done with this topic
after this they just want to make one
other point because you brought it up
I'm not gonna rehash all the reasons why
Michael Jackson is definitely guilty as
hell I'm gonna mention one other thing
that I hadn't yet mentioned Jackson as
we've established admitted to sleeping
in bed with little boys many times
multiple times he admitted it now even
if I were to accept the argument that he
may have done this originally in an
innocent not creepy way which I do not
accept that argument I think there's no
way that a man invites a boy and it was
bed for non creepy reasons even one time
but even if I were to accept that when
Jackson was was accused in 1992 or 93
and yet he ended up paying off his
accusers and back then this issue of
sleeping in bed with little boys came up
and he said oh so completely innocent
ideas of just a childlike love that we
share even if you're dumb enough to fall
for that back in 1993 well he kept doing
it okay it came up again 12 years later
when he was on trial and yet again he
was sleeping in bed with little boys he
kept doing it so at what point em at
what point you think do you do you think
that like how many times does he need to
sleep in bed with little was I how many
times doesn't need to be accused and
then keep on doing it before you will
admit that okay maybe there's something
going on here because even if he was i
confused enough to think that there is
nothing wrong with sleeping in bed with
little boys and weird enough to even
want to do that in the first place
well okay back in 1993 he was told this
is
appropriate it makes you look like a
pedophile totally inappropriate yeah you
shouldn't do that so now he knows if he
didn't before and he keeps doing it why
would he keep doing it was he sued what
is he standing on principles like some
got principal no I will sleep in bed
with strange boys I died principal I was
I'm going to fight for my right to do
that is that what you really think now
if he's a pedophile which he was then
then we can understand why he kept doing
it because he had a compulsion and
that's what pedophiles do they this is
why pedophiles need to be locked in
prison forever because they have a
compulsion they they can't control it
and they keep on doing it even though if
they know that they're destroying their
life in the process not to mention will
destroying the lives of the people of
their victims so that we we understand
that we know that that happens so it's
easy to explain it in that way but if
you're if you're latched on to this idea
of innocence how could you possibly
explain him continuing to do it even
after being multiple accused of child
molestation and he keeps on doing it did
he have did he have a non pedophilic
compulsion to sleep with little boys is
that even a thing no okay
just if I need to illustrate my point
imagine that you work as a loss
prevention officer at a department store
loss prevention those are the guys that
go around making sure you're not
stealing stuff so imagine you work as a
loss prevention at a at a store and you
you see a guy take a candy bar and put
it in his pocket and and then start to
walk away and so now 99 times out of 100
in your job when you see a guy put a
candy bar in his pocket or put anything
in their pocket that they didn't pay for
they're trying to steal that's that's
what thieves do that is what shoplifters
do so let's say you stopped him and he
says oh no no I was gonna pave it I know
I oh you're not supposed to put stuff in
your pocket before you pay but I didn't
realize I know it's totally innocent be
ignorant stop being ignorant no I I
would never do that I I just put it in
my pocket for safekeeping before I bring
it to the to the counter that's all
totally innocent
and calm down now even though in your
experience every single time someone
puts something in their pocket before
paying for it they are trying to steal
it so there's no reason at all to think
that this guy is different but let's
just say that you're you're you're in a
really good mood and you feel like being
generous and nice and charitable or
maybe you find out that the guy has a
really good singing voice and you see
you know he's a good singer no way you
could have done it so so then you let it
slide you say alright fine but you know
look but you tell him listen don't put
things in your pocket before you pay for
them because that's what shoplifters do
and it makes it look like shoplifter
it's not at a very very least that's not
appropriate don't do that well what if
he comes back the next week and does it
again then you stopped him again he says
oh oh oh no no no no no I didn't mean it
that was so totally no I was innocent
again I was just inside yeah I know
until you let him go again and then he
comes back a third time few weeks later
he's putting stuff in his pocket again
and then he comes back a fourth how many
times does he need to do it em before
you realize that he's oh he's actually
he is not only a shoplifter but he's a
kleptomaniac who can't control himself
and that's why he keeps doing it I mean
does he have to do it 20 times before
you conclude that maybe he's just like
every other shoplifter ever in history
so hopefully you see the comparison
between these two things if that example
is not enough to illustrate to you if
that won't convince you then I then
there's nothing that can be said all
right finally from Justin hi Matt's
important question for you where do you
think levy on bail ends up this officer
levy on bail the Steelers running back
who refused to play last year for the
Steelers which has a Ravens fan that was
a love that that was great
the Steelers are imploding and I'm
taking so much joy in it where do I
think levy on bail ends up as a free
agent I'm hoping the Ravens they'll talk
about that I as a Ravens fan but I do
think that he's obviously demanding a
lot of money and I'm in the school of
thought that or I am in that I'm in the
camp that believes that running backs
are that position is is vastly over
valued and layin bells a little bit
different because he's also a good
receiver so he has more value because of
that but generally speaking the thing
with running backs is number one they
get injured very easily and quickly even
more so than other positions number two
running back is a position where very
often you find these guys who the you
have a the plummet I guess the the
quality production plummet happens very
quickly and suddenly at that position
more so than any other position on the
football field where you could have a
guy that is you know 2,000 yards from
scrimmage all-star All Pro and then like
two years later he can barely crack
2,000 yards and this happens all the
time it's just the way the position
works so you got to be very careful
about investing any kind of money in it
and then also it's it's just it's really
easy to find running backs who can you
know get you 1,400 yards from scrimmage
and to find them in the third or fourth
round of the draft or to you know find a
kind of diamond in the rough and free
agency or it's really easy to do the
Ravens have been doing it for a long
time they find these guys they get a
good two seasons out of them they find
another guy it's one of those positions
where it's really easy to do that unlike
say cornerback a wide receiver or
quarterback where it's a lot harder to
find real talented running back you can
find real talent pretty easily pretty
cheaply so that's that's problem living
I'm Bell's gonna run into that it just
wouldn't make any sense to give him some
long-term super expensive deal just
because of the way the position works
alright we will leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed